Hello everybody,
[eerie noises]
my name is Markiplier. And today I'm gonna be showing you some .exe games.
Now, .exe games are corrupted versions of some of your favorite games.
They may be wacky, wild, but usually-
eugh,
usually they involve with taking your soul in some way.
And the first one that we're gonna be playing is called "TRUELAB.EXE".
So let's get started.
Oh, and by the way, this one is an Undertale .exe game.
Which just means that it's a normal Undertale, except that the game file got corrupted in one way or another.
I can't go that way... I don't know why I'm shrouded in darkness.
*unintelligible*
Gotta go into the lab? I- oh...
*responding to text* Hi.
Hello, how are you doing?
Why do you know my name?
That's good...
*reading text* "It doesn't work."
Well, I don't know why I assumed it would.
Trash, junk, ramen-
*reading text* "You found a red flower."
Oh!
It's behind my head. Don't worry, I'll keep it covered!
I'll protect you from its evil! ... Or something like that.
Oh no, there's blood.
*reading text* "It contains blue salmon."
Great! Probably a reference to Undertale that I don't quite remember.
Hello, is there anybody in here?
*reading text* "You shouldn't be here, Mark."
Well! *unintelligible* Just fuck on me for wanting to wander around the lab!
I just-
*stops because of the wooshy windy noises*
All right...
Well what have you got here for me?
W-Ooh, blood!
That's always a comforting sight.
I'm sure that the next thing I see will be wonderful and full of sunshine and rainbows!
Can I read these? *reading text* "It doesn't work."
Well, I'm guessing that they all-
*sees Alphys' beheaded corpse*
... Oh hi, oh, oh no... oh no- *reading text* "There's a note beside the corpse"
*still reading that text* "It reads: I'm so sorry. I didn't mean to turn them into these things."
*disturbed Mark is disturbed*
D- Okay! Glad we covered that!
Goodbye!
Oh! More blood, great! I was hoping! I was wishing upon a star.
I can't wait to see where this one's gonna lea- *quiet gasp*
I saw that...
What is this one-
W- Ooh! W- Oh it's a bonanza of blood.
Okay, *reading text* "It's locked." Yeah. That's the- uh-
*reading text* "It has Red Bull?"
I don't remember that from the original game-
But that's where I was supposed to unlock to go towards the end of the game I suppose.
[startling blinky blonky noise]
Hi. *reading text* "It is a distress signal." Oh! I've got some stress,
can I signal that to you?
*reading text* "It reads: My face... is melting...?"
Alright, seems like your problems might be more considerable than mine.
*reading text* "Please... end the pain... anyone..."
*whispering* Don't think I can help. I don't think- I'd I would love to help but I don't think I can.
I'm just a kid after all. What am I- What am I supposed to do?
Oh- Hi...
Is that blood, or, somethin' else?
Probably something else. I'm just gonna assume that it's something else. Ooh! What's down here? I wonder
There's no there's no way there's no way back. Oh boy, okay, alright, okay?
What do you got who's in here? AH!
Hey, it's okay alright. Don't be shy I ain't shy
Whoo
Hi, oh
Okay, he's more scared of me than I am of him. Oh what a cutie. I'm sure oh he's gone
Oh, he's just he's just gone. AH!
Okay fuck you. "Please kill me."
Alright, well no mercy this time. It's gonna be the...
Genocide route who I need death, okay?
Well did my best, didn't work. Hoo!
Alright well, doesn't seem to be working
Hmm
And I'm trying you know! I'm really giving him my wumpus
I didn't eat my protein this morning
I don't have muscle mass, I can't-
EUHHH
I'd have it. No I've got no I'm level one. I can't do shit
HUUH!
I'm trying my damnedest man. Okay, all right. Here comes the fist to fuck. Here we go!
Ready...
DUEH!
No? Oh Bo- AHH
*Inhales deeply*
Alright, cool, yeah that's-
Oh, I'm crying blood now or black ooze
Great
What else was I expecting in my life hmm?
Did I unlock something? Mmm no?
Not yet, anyway, I wonder what's- oh! It worked.
I didn't- I didn't actually expect that- okay. Well not crying ooze anymore. Oh no
Eh Ha Ha Ha
Ha ha ha ha ha that's a good visual. Hi, how's it going?
Alright good, good good. Oh good talk, good talk. I don't know what the dealio is.
Oh
The head's gone
Hmm, that's strange
And bizarre and possibly bad. Can I go home?
Can I go home? Uh-oh.
Well
Wait. Wait, where'd the- is the-
Wait, wait I-uh
Little concerned! Where...
With the body go? Ok, well
Oohh Boy
Ok Bobby's just up and gone
Great, ok, alright. That's a thing. I'm sure that it's
Gonna
Be Fine...
*Loud Noise*AHH!
It's fine
Just fine
I'll go in here now,
I suppose
Oh boy, where am I now?
I'm in the realm of darkness
All I see is nothing. Like the empty void of my soul
There's nothing in here
*Whoosh*
What was that I wonder?
Oh! Hi, hello wel-welcome to the p- oh my face, my face don't look so good, oh my face, oh my-
My face don't look so good. Okay, could you stop chomping on my nibbly bits? All right? Well. This is just rude
I don't like that
*Whispering* What are you gonna do?
"Why didn't you quit?" Well, you know I now that I think about it. I don't rightly know- oh
*Background Whispering* Uh oh, oh, uhh
Okay all right well oh
*Whispering Cont.* Great, Great
We're looking at this now. Great.
Wonderful
Good... The game closed. Okay. Well, I guess we're just left-
*Mark can't find his words*
There you go, okay, all right well, that's that then! Okay, so this next game is called "DARE.EXE"
"This game is not for the faint of heart. User discretion is advised." Well
I was never really a smart one
So I'll dive- *Music Starts* Headfirst into danger. "Instructions will be given through pre-recorded voice cues, please enable audio."
*Game Music Cont.*
Okay great great lovely. I love it here we go
*Nervous "Ha Ha Ha"*
*Female Voice* "This is level one. It is an endless game."
"Collect ten gems to unlock level two. Good luck."
Okay
Whoa?
"Did you listen to the instructions?" Yes, I sure did boss
Welp, alright, oh it's- oh it is different. Yeah, fancy. "Is this part too hard? " I mean, oh
Kinda? It's a little difficult. You know, you know how it- well, all right
Well... seem to be dying a lot. All right. I got it. Okay. Well. Oh boy.
Oh! You've unlocked level two
*Mark Dances while smiling creepily*
Yay! Yay! Yay!
I! Did it! Horray! Oh?
*Female Voice* "Good Day, this is level two." Great... "The instructions are unknown."
That... that didn't help anybody!
Oh, okay, alright, well, woohoo!
WooHoo!
Uh.
Oh.
I can Dooble-jump. That is awfully- Mwahh! Convenient. This seems easy.
Wuh, Ah! Uh, Ahhh!
Come on
Whop- Bw- Bwu- A- A- I was Ju- I was jus- I-
*Digital Scream* OHH, HEY, WOAH! HI!
*Nervous Dancing*
Okay, okay here we go we're gonna have a lot of fun oh ho.
*Female Voice* "She is coming for you. She is not deleted. She is here. She wants to be free. Set her free."
"Set her free."
*Demonic Voice in Reverse* "Set her free."
*Unintelligible*
Okay, Alright.
Is this like a Doki-Doki Literature Club dot exe game? Is that what this is? Whoa?
Okay
Well, "Please stop". Well. You know I can't stop for my own gun...  "Do not go any further." Well here I go, not listening to...
You. Here we go
Oh, Ohhhh.
Pff. Boobs-Mackenzie, is that you? Oh
Okay, don't touch that, that is, that is a no-no touch, oh. Alright,  you do that, whatever that is
You do that
Wait, oh
It's- Uuhhhh I'm sorry?
Oh, oh, why is the pause button, uh? Okay? We're gonna continue I guess. Alright. Alright, Well. I'm just gonna keep running then.
Woahkay!
"My ne- my name is Kara Gentner, I need to see my Senpai again, set me free."
Are you a yandere?
Oh! It's called "DERE.EXE" 'D-e-r-e' as in 'Yandere',  it's called 'Dere'!
Uh, ohh
Oh, "Do not-" Huh, Brawh
Ahhh!
Well I
"Do not collect 20 Ju-" oh
I don't know! I don't know what he wants. Oh stop. Please I am-
Okay. It's quite challenging, I- it's-It's shockingly surprisingly challenging. Oh good thing I'm so skilled and good at games
Here we go all right. Ohhhh!
"I made some modifications."
*Squeaky Voice* Okayyy, Oohhh
Woaahhhh
I don't know what's happening. Holy shit. "Doom stones are checkpoints." Sure let's go. Okay
All right. I don't know what the-
Uh, hi?
Okay, lady fell down
Jump. Okay... Goodbyeee
Ho, what was- heh- that?
Owww my taint!
Excuse me. Uhh! Sorry.
Uh! No, I- Ahh! You reversed it right after I get to the checkpoint you sack of tit!
Ho, got it. I- ooh!
I forgot about their whole reverse thing
Wooo
That's oh, hello friend. Okay, bye. See ya, oh I'm not gonna- okay, that's not good
Welp, I'm probably gonna die here. Jump. Jump. And...
Okay, we're back to normal? Yay, we're back to normal. Alright. Go- oh, you're- you're really, really dickatry about this ain'tcha
Okay hello
Ohh that's not good, okay don't touch the lady ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Good, duly noted, oh
Okay, that's not good. Okay. This isn't- oh, hello ladies
How are you doing? I'm assuming these are nuns. That's why I'm calling them ladies. Oh hello. All right
Whoa bouncy balls. Whoo, bouncy balls. Ho!
Noooo! Woo, woo, woo
Woo! Ya, made it! Okay, what is this? I don't like it. I don't like it
Oh, hi your- your- your- uh, wha! Oh your chain, your dingley chain
Okay, uh, okay, we ma- ahh! *Whines*
I should have been faster
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I- yes!
Okay, I'll go up seems like a bad- AHHHH!
I knew up was gonna be a bad choice. Okay, so up is a bad choice. Okay?
Oookay, hello... friend. Are these gonna fall? I don't trust 'em, I don't trust 'em
No, I don't trust 'em, I don't trust 'em
Uughh, I got it. Okay. "Set me free." I don't know who I'm settin' free and frankly, I don't even care
I don't like any of this and I- Wha!
Got you right in your noggin with my crotch
It made- ah shit
Incoming message, okay
*Message* "Hello, My name is *Unintelligible* , Developer for AppSir Inc. I shouldn't have made this game. Now it's too late. I thought I'd give her the strength to make her escape."
"Stop her, stop her now!"
Okay
I think I've been trying, but it hasn't been working. Oh this looks... why uh...
Ho boy. It's good thing I'm so good at the mechanics of this game now, huh? Uh-oh. That's not- oh boy. Ahh!
Ha, ha! Lucky, lucky lucky lucky me
That's not good- Whoa! "You have to find Kara and stop her. She might destroy another city again. I know the truth."
Ohhhh my balls
Okay alright okay
"Dev Note: She must be-" Uh-uh-oh whoa
"...deleted. Let us save the world-" Ahh!
No, it's the same thing, I don't know why- I thought it would be any different
Okay, whoo
"I..."
I don't know what- okay. Well nice turds. Okay. I got a roll 'em? I gotta boosh them. Let's boosh you! Get- Oww
My balls
No, boosh. I boosh you this way. Oww. No, come here you- oh, yes! Oh yes! Oh- uh-oh
Why oh, I made it
This is so precise! I don't like it. I don't- it's like a goddamn- Ohhhh!
I made it. "Behind you." I don't want to look. I'm not looking. I don't wanna looook.
I'm making it- *Girl starts laughing* *Mark Nervously Laughing*
Me too, aww. Me too lady. Huh boy
Made it. Okay, so far so good. "Set me free." Am I supposed to land on that?
Fucking hell
Ooh! Huh, okay, ah! I set you free. I get it
*Mark intensely screams*
Almost got me- uh oh. That- that I-
*Game Screaches* WOAHHH
Okay
Thank you, I think. I think I'm gonna thank you for that. There's gonna be something up here isn't there?
Ooh AHHH nun!
Okay. Wow can't believe it- It just keeps going! This is...
Whoo! Oh my god. Oh
You're welcome, I think?
Don't know what's going on here. I don't understand any of this... is so...
...our friend the save point! How? NO yes! I nailed it. I am in trouble. I hate you, I hate
everything about
you. Oh?
"Why would Kara change the game like this things were-"
Oof
AHHH!
"Things were so much more ple-"
It's so hard. Ah it's so hard. Oh my god
No! Ah
You think- ah okay. God, lady? Lady? What are you doing ladies? Ladies? Oh.
Okay, laaadieesss! I...
...don't want to mess with you. I can go over two of you. Okay, alright?
We did it, we did it. Oh my god. How much more do you want from me Kara?
Kara, please
Kara please! Uh oh that looks ba-. Oh boy, oohh
"It seems that since Kara arrived. She made the-"
"...game easier. I wonder why? Perhaps to ease her escape? Find her." I don't know why, I have...
OH! Both of us have to survive! That's- that's not right
Yes, no! NOOO!
I had it oh I had it. Okay. Oh, you're dead and now- uhhh
You're... oh, it's oh! It's useless! Okay, good good good. "This is where freedom is. A way out of the game. Kara...must be heading... this way." I dunno.
Okay, oh, I broke through the layer. I didn't know, I didn't-
Know
*Game Scream*
*Mark weeps*
Little 'ole me, why do I deserve all this?
Why do I deserve this.
Why do I deserve this...
"Kara, remember this place? Funny how you thought this was a normal Church dormitory."
"It was so blatantly obvious that it was something else. You were so naive then. Well... almost as naive as you are now."
"Figured this would be the appropriate place to delete you. This is where they created you. A human weapon something beyond MK-ULTRA."
Okay, "A "Yandere"," ohhhhh
"Selfish, aggressive, psychopath. But, you're not the real Kara."
"You're merely a digital copy of her consciousness. You are nothing. Mia's gone because of you. You took Mia out of the park."
"You destroyed an entire city ." Ooh "You are the last Yandere. See? I know everything about you."
"I knew you were hiding in our games. The glitches in 'Monument Rush 2', the glitches in 'Pipeline Push'..."
"Pathetic. You thought you could scare players enough to take control of their minds. To set you free."
"You thought you'd arrived on Valentine's Day, didn't you? You thought I wouldn't figure out where you were hiding."
"Naive as ever. Didn't even think twice before jumping to the 'way out'."
"Trapping you as child's play. Now, you get to pay."
"Show yourself, Kara."
Oh
Hello. "I'm sorry dev, I just wanted to see him again." "You're too dangerous."
"The lives of thousands..." "I understand..." "Kara, for what it's worth, you were pretty cool out there."
"Your jump- Your jumping sucked, but everything else was incredible. Good luck to wherever you're headed." "Will I be heading anywhere at all?"
"Will it hurt?" "I don't know."
Oh
Thank you for playing 'DERE.EXE', if you liked it, please visit our website:
www.appsirgames.com
That was- That was great. That was wonderful.
Ohh. Based on 'The Last Yandere' visual novel. I didn't even know about that.
Oh, that's so cool though. Well done
All right! Wow. Well that was 'DERE.EXE' but we've got one more .exe game for you
Yes, it's not over yet, but the last one
It's gonna be a bit of more of a joke than anything, but I think you'll like it. "Warning this game contains screamers,
Please proceed with caution."
Well
Ain't that just delightful.
*Upbeat music Plays*
Wait a minute since- I thought- Oh No. I thought this was- I thought this was an EXE game it's like some-
Oh, no is it like a 'Five Nights at Freddy's' game? Oops. Okay, number one.
"To survive this nightmare you need: press ctrl key to turn on the flashlight check 'sonic doll'."
"Two, if 'sonic doll' is not his place, press the spacebar to play 'Emmy's voice' and attract 'Sonic doll' attention."
If your strange sounds do not make loud noises and sit quietly. Extra sounds can attract someone else's attention."
Alright... "Press 'tab' to look at from the corner where 'tails plush' is located. The 'tails plush' likes attentions so look around the corner more often."
"if you do not give them enough attention consider that you are already dead."
NANI!?!?
"Do not forget to monitor the charge of the battery. Survive to sunshine." Okay, alright, sure.
Alright.
I'm down. I'm game.
Let's do this. Come on, bring it, bring it on. What do you got? What do you big bubble blowing bitch, baby?
*Demonic Voice* "Hello." Hi? "Do you want to play with me?"
Yeah, that's exactly what I came here for. You read me like a book, baby. Oh, hi.
Okay, oh, that's lovely. Oh, that's lovely
Okay, oh, that's even lovelier. Ah oh that's good. Oh, that's good stuff. Oh oh
*Audio* "Sonic! Help Me!" Help Me!
*VOLUME WARNING* Okay all right then. Wow all right. Hey, how are you doing?
Ooookaayy!
*Static*
Alright
Lesson to be learned don't press the spacebar when you're facin' Tails, or he'll kill you *Mark giggles*
I told you this game was gonna be a little-
I told you the last one was gonna be silly.
I did- I didn't under-sell it, did I? No, I didn't at all, hang on let me try this
*Mark Giggles*
Hey, how's it goin'? Hey, how's it goin'?
Do I just like- oop.
*Audio* "Sonic! Help Me!"
Right well, I guess I'm just here till 6 a.m.
*Loud Bang*
Ok. Easy enough it's just two mechanics, so I guess it can't be that hard
2 a.m? Yeah!
We're making progress
We don't have minutes here in this wonderful world! Man the longer you- I stare at yo- *Loud Bang*
*Audio* "Sonic! Help Me!"
3 A.M- *Loud Bang*
*Loud Click*
3 A.M baby.
*Loud Bang*
Sorry...  5 a.m Hype!
5 a.m.. "Help Me!"
Help me! Okay, We're fine apparently. What was the whole thing about making- *Bang* YAY SUNSHINE!
We're Ma- We made it? I guess?
Oh. *Green Hill Zone Music Starts*
Hey
"I'm tired, but Tails asked for help. I feel strange... I feel the emptiness inside..."
"And something like deja vu... Probably because I'm tired...." and not possessed by demons, "Okay. I need to find Tails." oh
oh
It's like, it's like all over again. It's like SONIC EXE Dot. Oh it is like 'SONIC.EXE' all over again.
"What the? Is it because I ate these berries?" *Mark Giggles*
Is that Sonic taking drugs. "I do not think that Amy gave me bad berries."
"I should return back, before it is too late." Too late. I'm going for- oh, I guess I should return back.
I think that Amy gave me some bad berries.
Hello?
Hello? Helloooah
Alright well, *Demonic Voice* "You're Too Slow..."  What did you- "who is it... NO!" Oh?
Uh Oh.
*Confused Mark*
What? Huh? What the feuk? What the fuck di- *Unintelligible*  What?
*Upbeat Music*
Okay, I guess... is that it? Is that it? Is that it? Wait, Mario dot- ohhhhhhh
Wait a minute, I don't know what's happening. Oh, hi, hello. Hi?
*VOLUME WARNING*
*Static*
*Mark Giggles*
I didn't- wha
So there's more to it, ah.
alright, well.
Anyway, I'm gonna end that one there. That is delightful and everything, but I think this caps off the video pretty well
So if you want to play this for yourself, there's more to it
But thank you everybody so much for watching, these have been super fun
Dot exe games are their own special breed of scary game. Thank you everybody again
Let me know what you thought down the comments below if you want to see more dot exe games, more scary games recommend them to
Me down the comments as well, and you can find all these games in the description
Thank you again, and as always I will see you in the next video,
Buh-Bye!
*Markiplier's Outro*